and the other side of it
so again ernest becker but also victor
franklin recommended highly manchester
meeting
uh bernard williams he's a moral
philosopher
they kind of argue that this knowledge
of death even if we
often don't contemplate it we do at
times
and the very the what you call the curse
which i agree with you it's a
it's a curse and a blessing that we're
able to contemplate our own mortality
that gives meaning to life so death
gives meaning to life
is what victor frankl's argues i would
probably argue the same there's
something about the scarcity of life
and contemplating that that makes each
moment
that much sweeter is there something to
that
i think it's individual in my case it's
completely wrong
i appreciate you saying that i don't get
joy out of
every day because i think i'm gonna die
yeah i get joy out of every day because
every day is joyous
and i make it that way and even if i
would if i thought i was gonna live
forever
i would still be enjoying this moment
just as much
and i bet you would too well that's uh
i think about that a lot i i think
it's very difficult to know i'm almost
afraid
that i wouldn't enjoy it as much if i
was immortal i'm almost afraid to want
to be immortal or
to live longer because
it perhaps is a kind of justification
for me to accept that i'm going to die
is saying like oh if i was immortal i
wouldn't be able to enjoy life as much
as i do
but it's very possible that i would
enjoy just as much
um of course enjoying life whether
you're mortal or not
takes work like it it requires you to
have
the right kind of freedom of mind you
can discover
you can focus your mind on the ugliness
of life
there's plenty of ugly things in this
world and you can focus on them you can
complain
whenever like you know if it's raining
outside
you can you can focus on the fact that
you have shelter and you enjoy the the
hell
out of it or you can enjoy running in
the rain when it's warm
and like the the beauty of nature just
being one with nature
or you can just complain this
weather again in boston
and there you see they're always raining
or freezing damn it and like
um that the same the same thing with
like wi-fi going out on airplanes
like you can either complain about like
stupid wi-fi and on jetblue or something
or you could say like how incredible it
is that i can fly through the sky and in
a matter of hours be anywhere else in
the world
and then it could also on occasion watch
uh like check email and even watch
movies through this while connecting
through satellites that are flying to
space so it's a matter of perspective
and perhaps
there's an extra level of work required
when you're immortal
because it's easier when you're immortal
or live longer to
uh to be lazy to delay stuff but if
you're not
you can still derive the same amount of
joy it's possible
it's possible it's definitely possible
in my life
i i went from being the nothing's
working to
every day is great to wake up to and i i
think even if you
live i think you're gonna live forever
you can you can enjoy every day
what i do is everything's relative we
can compare ourselves to our neighbor
who has more money
or to the flight that should have had
wi-fi or
which is what i do i'm still six years
old remember what a six-year-old does
says look i can when i tell
my fingers to form a fist they actually
do that that's really cool
that's how i live my life you know i'm i
can pick up on your desk here this metal
object it's a metal cube
about an inch by an inch by an inch and
i i tell myself not
not about cubes but about inanimate
objects
probably once a day i'll say i'm a
living thing
i can think i can move i can eat i am
full of energy
and there's that leaf or this cube here
that will never be alive
that's what i look at and compare myself
to
and for as long as i live if it's
forever of course it won't be but
even if it was forever the relative to
this lump of metal on this table here
we are wondrous things in the universe
and probably the most wondrous things in
the universe yeah we're able to
deeply appreciate the leaf or the cube
and deeply appreciate ourselves which is
uh
it can be a curse but it's mostly a gift
especially when you're such a beautiful
poem
now i'm six i'm as clever as clever so i
think i'll be six
now forever and ever that's a good thing
to aspire to
your uh your grandmother was on to
something david this is uh
incredible conversation i'm a huge fan
of your work so
thank you for wasting your valuable time
with me today i really really appreciate
it this was awesome thank you for having
me on lex appreciate it
you